We need to be part of a community to survive.
We're born so helpless
that someone needs to look after us until we're maybe 10 years old,
so our brain evolves towards food.
We need to be in that community.
So whether I like it or not,
not being invited to the friend's wedding,
my lizard brain is generating the same response
as if I'm about to be pushed out from my community.
So science explains quite nicely why fairness is good
and why unfairness makes us really defensive,
but science also shows that in a fair environment,
not only do we all want to be the square,
but we tend to be the square,
and this allows other people to be fair in turn.
This creates a beautiful fairness circle.
But while we start off fair ...
one drop of unfairness contaminates the whole pool,
and unfortunately, there's plenty of drops in that pool.
So our effort should be to filter out
as much unfairness as we can from everywhere,
starting from our communities, starting from our companies.
I worry about this a lot because I lead a team of 3,000 excellent people,
and the difference between 3,000 happy, motivated team workers
and 3,000 clock-watchers is everything.
So the first thing I try to do in my fairness crusade
is to try to take myself out of the equation.
That means being aware of my own biases.
For example, I really like people who say yes
to whatever I suggest.
(Laughter)
But that's not very good for the company
and not very good for anyone who has different ideas.
So we try to actively promote a culture of diversity of opinions
and diversity of character.
The second thing we do is a little more procedural.
We look at all the rules, the processes, the systems in the company,
the ones we use to take decisions and allocate resources,
and we try to get rid of anything that's not very clear,
not very rational, doesn't make sense,
and we also try to fix anything that's limiting
the transfer of information within the company.
We then look at the culture and the motivation for the same reasons.
But my point is that however hard you look at the rules,
the processes, the systems -- and we have to do that --
but however hard we look,
we're never going to do enough to get to the real essence of fairness.
That's because the last mile of fairness requires something else.
It's about what people's emotions are,
what their needs are,
what's going on in their private lives,
what society needs.
These are all questions and elements
that are very hard to put into a spreadsheet, into an algorithm.
It's very hard to make them part of our rational decision.
But if we miss these, we're missing key important points,
and the outcome is likely to feel unfair.
So we should cross-check our decisions with our fairness center switched on.
Is it right that this guy should get the job he's really hoping to get?
Is it right that this guy should be fired?
Is it right that we should be charging so much for this product?
These are tough questions.
But if we take the time to ask ourselves
whether the rational answer is the right one ...
we all know deep inside what the answer is.
We've known since we were babies.
And to know what the right answer is
is pretty cool for decision-making.
And if we turn on our hearts,
that's the key to getting the real best out of people,
because they can smell it if you care,
and only when you really care will they leave their fears behind
and bring their true selves to work.
So if fairness is a keystone of life,
why isn't every leader making it their priority?
Wouldn't it be cool to work in a company that was more fair?
Wouldn't it be great to have colleagues and bosses
that were selected and trained for fairness and for character
and not based on 60-year-old GMATs?
Wouldn't it be nice to be able to knock on the door
of a Chief Fairness Officer?
We'll get there, but why is it not happening now?
Well, partly, it's because of inertia,
partly, it's because fairness isn't always easy.
It requires judgment and risk.
Drilling that eighth well was a risk.
Promoting the guy who didn't finish high school was a risk.
Building a cheese factory in Ecuador was a risk.
But fairness is a risk worth taking,
so we should be asking ourselves,
where can we take this risk?
Where can we push ourselves a little bit further,
to go beyond what's rational and do what's right?
Thank you.
(Applause)